if you're just joining this is a
thematic tournament I've been doing
more of these recently so every game
this tournament will start
in the Royal Lopez this is a new uh
about to say chess.com this new leechas
openings page
uh it's still in beta but it's really
really cool tool I'll give a lot of
stats about all different types of
openings
um and actually within the Royal Lopez
there's a lot of different sub
variations
the morphe defense okay morphe defense
that's just a main line and that can
lead into a lot of things
steinits Berlin
classical bird cozio
Queen F6 whatever this is the schliemann
I used to play this
the Nuremberg what's a Nuremberg
this looks terrible
I mean there's other lines where Knight
E5 works but I don't think it works here
also have pentatonic on we turn
pentatonic off
foreign
is this playable for white
King D7 oh G6 is even playable wait what
G6 is better for black
wait
it says minus 2.2 but then when you play
the move
it says
yeah White's not worse
but maybe it's complicated
wow
what an unnecessary line to analyze
never seen this before boxer thing made
though Knight C3
I guess one reason to play this
variation is black is you bait white
into going for this and then you play
King D7 and blocks to stop a piece
White's checks will fizzle out
Spanish counter Gambit I've never seen
this one either what is this one
there's not too much time left about
about 85 seconds
to cram in all my opening crap
the Spanish counter gambits it looks fun
but it's just a path opening 95
yeah this does not look good for black
unless there's Queen G5
oh this lion takes
takes
Queen F3
oh queen of three is a funny move
wow oh no White's Queen but white wins
it back
and whatever one Queen E4
Queen E2 King E2 A6 man
oh that's a cool line actually
and I have three Queen E7
okay I could maybe imagine myself
playing such a line
um
let me close out my tabs
let's try and focus
so if you're just joining this is a Roy
Lopez super Blitz Arena
um I might put this whole thing on
YouTube
trying to play more thematic tournaments
they're good for YouTube titles because
I can I can hopefully title this one
beating everyone with the Royal Lopez
here we go oh my layouts wait let me
disable
I forgot I was doing this okay
hopefully this is better G6
play Knight C3
and let me make the board a little bit
bigger
yeah I was doing some blindfold earlier
um
this is already looking
playable
D4
D4 takes Knight D5
let's try it
it's a Gambit I mean there's three
attackers on the d-pawn
and uh
yeah something
something is probably good for black
but there are some interesting ideas
I wanted to play Bishop G5
a Poland prevents me
but looks like I'm winning back upon
Knight's pinned
C3
and Life Goes On
oh that move doesn't work it almost
looks cool though
let's play Queen D2
idea to uh Tie Down The Rook
G5 man
yeah with G5 it's it's gonna say it's
not lightly black hole Castle kingside
but
of
okay the king should be shaky
still going after this Pawn
attacking The Rook
to go back King H7 Bishop C2
we go Castle
this way
so I want to play E5 and then Bishop V2
Queen D3 and eventually checkmates
and now the Bishops attacked
but Queen I5 I'm tied down to this
bishop so I Bishop C2
and then I'll take
uh there's Queen A2
that should be okay though
Queen F5
okay threatening made in one
there should be B1 keeps me safe
um
I wonder if I can take
looks acceptable
oh no
my plan was check and win the bishop
I forgot Bishop h6's check though
[Music]
it's still playable somehow I mean I
just gave back the piece
but we're still getting a position
[Music]
uh check check let's try this
so there is Rook D2 take Bishop T2
okay G4 is attacked and the Rooks
attacked two
and not my proudest moment there
I think I can play this first
um
this move
or maybe take first and then this
so I'm preventing rookie 2 attacking the
bishop attacking the pawn
oh good move
I gotta play quicker
trying to activate the king
oh my Rook
oh not my happiest start
what's that Meme that's going around
something about The Rook
my Pawn
I mean I still have a pawn storm
Free Pawn
Outpost
off the color Bishops
should mean it's a draw right
I'm gonna trap the man almost trapping
the bishop there
um
not much hope Poland gave me a little
bit of Hope though
okay
I survived for longer than necessary
there
oh unfortunate starts
mistakes happen
I'm beating everyone with a Roy Lopez
and then in parentheses except the first
dude
this this is going to be the name of the
Future YouTube video
uh
okay I'm gonna play the Roy Lopez
counter gamut this is the opening I
learned
right before the tournament began
I feel like this is already a nice
position for black
E4 about to come
a night is
the night it's trapped but there's a
problem here
yeah Knight C3 oh dear
got a little bit too feisty
okay so it's I guess a Gambit I'm down
the pawn
and these first few games are kind of a
wake-up call
um
I'm gonna have to play this
I'm in some trouble Rook G5 with a one
upon
um I think I'll just Castle
[Music]
and there's Queen G5
or a queen before
getting my coordinates confused
on the plus side I have the bishop pair
decently open position
okay this is something
take this
and it's getting messy there's a really
cool move here look at this move Knight
T2
I think it's just a fancy way of trading
but the point is the queen is tied down
to the rook and the Knight is tied down
to this Rook
so whatever it takes tonight I'm gonna
win one of the Rooks the only issue is
my Brook is hanging
so yeah we're just Trading
a very fancy but somehow I want back my
Pawn
uh because I took on B2
okay
and now I'm up upon
so now it's white playing the counter
counter gamut
this Pawn's hanging
and there's almost a really cool idea
[Music]
um
let's just defend both
less cool but very stable
okay
so if well first of all I'm starting C5
hitting the Knight and the Rook I think
I play C5 anyway
C5 Knight B3 though hmm
[Music]
Queen C5
I really want to play this move rookie
eight but then after it takes King H2 I
can't take back
it's actually a very confusing position
I think I just played Bishop Bishop E6
C5 Knight B3
and
there there there
maybe I go for this
Knight B3 Queen A6 takes Queen C6
takes and then takes
foreign
[Music]
month strong baby
a very strong baby
thank you Alex
that's a good move
this move
no I don't
okay what are the odds my opponent
allows me to Checkmate on G2
also I think I'm winning one of these
things
yeah there's no way to keep the rook in
Knight Defender Let's Go Eric
like you see back
it was a good fight though
opponent played well for the rating
[Music]
okay threatening mates
now pinning The Rook
oh D4 is a move to be careful
just hide
what was my Bishop doing
there we go
okay I took work
that's the tournament
let me update my settings
um settings preferences
which is going to turn off the keyboard
input
it was a join command not updated
commands edit join
okay oh we have a Berlin
um
okay it's Castle
okay I feel like this is going to be
very non-theoretical let's play C3 and
go for D4
one of the
main ways to
just to play in the Spanish
and like already after E5 there's a
interesting idea
to play Bishop D3
although
it's probably worth trying to develop
more things first
see where this bishop wants to go
I'm already dreaming of Greek gift
though
like Bishop D3 Bishop H7 Knight G5
9 C3 first
any funny stories lately of being
recognized in public
um
the most recent time I was recognized
it was about a week ago
I was actually driving between Chicago
and St Louis
and
like what to do here Bishop F4
and I stopped at a a Panera Bread
and I was just having a meal I got the
the pick two
got my
what did I order some kind of sandwich
and soup
and then someone came up to me
and
the first thing they said was oh this is
so cool and they were so like Starstruck
to to like see me at this random Panera
Bread
because it was kind of a middle of
nowhere town
and they they said they watched me on on
YouTube
and they recognized me but they didn't
quite remember my name
and then they wanted a photo
I offered to like take a selfie but they
just wanted a photo of of me so
okay that was a nice Queen trade
uh Baxter tournaments
oh yeah if you want to join uh join
yeah join
the Roy Lopez Arena here
's supposed to be this new feature on
Twitch
called pin
as opposed to Fork
okay
customized for the next
40 minutes
oh
30 minutes how about okay cool
okay playing per I'm gonna berserk
I'll play D4
and take I think this is already like
really nice for white
yeah let's take this
targeting the pawn
okay so that was a lot of Trades
after all said and done lights up a pawn
trying to win another Pawn
um
getting close each word coming
kind of shifting gears
um
yeah not actually winning anything here
I think I'll I'll go for F4
good evening Eric good evening
Jonas savimbi
thanks for subbing
Double B says an item on my bucket list
is to meet you
someday hopefully
after I write your PhD thesis
I want to have fun
always repeat
three
okay
it's not simple though and G2 Falls
unless it doesn't fall
okay I have four Falls
I'm losing back upon I'll still be up
upon though
in 23 seconds
should be enough time
cutting off the king
idea G4
bc42
black beat me to it
yeah this should be clean
okay
there we go
so three games in
um top ten
yeah how the rocky starts trying to get
some Rhythm here
yeah I think um Z Nation made a good
point the opponent moved a little bit
too quickly towards the end
oh playing Ezra Zev
a mod on this channel
I have to show no mercy
uh let's play a shaman
I went through a very brief phase of
playing this in classical play
it was a long time ago
actually the first game I had in this
position like OTB I was playing the
white side
I lost like so quickly
okay
now there's a funny line here Queen D4
and like naturally white goes for this
the problem with this line for light is
after it takes takes my Rooks defended
by the queen
I'm pretty sure I've had this position
before
back
if white plays D4 is opposant forced
because I was threatening meat
I have to look up the rules
play 97
oh The Queen Is Almost trapped
I was supposed to play Queen F7 Bishop
E6
yeah no mercy here Queen F4 only move
I mean I'm up appease but that's kind of
the least of
White's problems
oh
now is on the sun Forest I really want
to take but then takes defends the queen
if it takes
oh there's a funny line let's go for
this
so the funny line is Queen F3 Bishop D5
takes and then oh no my Rook
and if queen queen E3 I still take and
say oh no my queen
that is a feel-good finish
if F4i windmill
actually F4 is just made in two
yeah I might as well show that
[Music]
um
yeah that was a nice opening trap uh
from back in the day
um I'm pretty sure I've I've had this
line at least once before on Lee chess
C player
it's black
oh maybe not
maybe it's a similar position though
uh it could be from this position
I've had this position a few times it's
the same idea
Queen defends
in UK I wake up to cold and missed your
stream oh I am now in Iloilo Philippines
cold beer warm sun hammock and live
stream Happy Days it sounds nice
anyway the thing I wanted to show if
Queen E3 I still take the pawn
and then if takes its mating and if
takes it's also mating
so
back to tournament
yeah think about this uh these sort of
thematic Arenas is if you don't play the
Spanish or if you don't play the
specific opening in the arena then it's
much easier to be out of your comfort
zone
oh playing Steven Willie
we have a Berlin
um I don't play The Proven that's white
I've seen so many games in this but uh
yeah as white I really haven't explored
it so much
I'm gonna go for uh what looks like a
reasonable setup
maybe it's a little bit slow
but I'm really just improvising here
and keeping things positional
four looks
like a move
please show some mercy in this game
if I do it won't be intentional Mercy
okay pawns are smiling
okay some end game black has a bishop
here but I have the four on three
majority
and this four and three majority it's
like almost impossible to make a past
Pawn
um
don't want to trade Knights
and ideas to bring up the king and Pawns
placing E2 first
as Knight could go Hobby
thinking of three King D King to E3
this could be a long grind
happy
uh
uh H4
as Knight wants to do things
so G4 the point is I'm not losing a pawn
after Knight E1
a threat is King E3
I whispered Hoppity Hoppity to you in
Vegas oh yeah that's what you're
supposed to say when the Night Moves
uh let's
go for
man Knight is really doing Hobby
Knight D4
foreign
[Music]
wow
yeah vlog's probably for Choice here and
maybe it's still equal
Black's pieces look nicer
am I getting mated
I was really close to being mated
and the Bishops attacked
offer some trade
wow
confusing move
doll my Pawn oh no
foreign
[Music]
the light is still doing Hobby
but I can too
copy
okay
oh what a crazy game
uh got some trickery I mean we were both
tricks at various points
and Bishop F5 was really really strong
I thought I was being clever but then
but it's still not easy because yeah
once the pawn moved to E6
okay
what a crazy game
so top three
25 minutes left Anything Can Happen
another month here we go here we go
playing DCM
okay let's mix up the opening even more
maybe I'll play a main line
I forgot it was my move
um actually I'll play the What's this
called steinants
there's a trap here if like plays D4 too
early but
not quite happening
okay we'll go for C5 that's typical
formation for black
against the Spanish
so this is a common idea
reposition the bishop
um I'll throw in H6
um
and queen d8 first
I'm scared of the night coming in
yeah we're both solid here
actually happy with the position a
little bit more space
um don't mind the trade of Bishops
so now there's some play
I can muster up
start with this
accepting the double Pawns
oh
the A4 is a very typical Spanish move
long-term ideas of Knight D4
yeah my Pawn is going to be weak
but White's pawns Also may be weak
okay and defending
offering the trade
I need to somehow
not lose my Rook I taken
Queen D6
really risky to do this
but the queen defends all the pawns I
want to push D3
and there's a couple checks but then
King G6
or King H7 first
there's a line where my king goes to G6
it's happening good evening Eric
good evening
and there's no time to calculate
oh dear
don't hurt me
I'm only King F3
oh yeah yeah
[Music]
well it has at least a draw
what's happening
no more checks
or no more good checks threatening this
and this
okay using my king as an attacker
let's go
oh man
opposition
okay what a game
okay berserking almost didn't pay off
until it did pay off
that was a crazy game I mean
my king somehow found shelter in White's
territory
and I was fortunate to cover like all
the key squares
okay back to tournaments
okay
I'm pretty busy on top here
fourth place
pauliste from Kosovo doing very well
playing vinayak
okay so we're going into kind of a main
line
yeah this is called the Yates variation
the main line is H3
there is a trap here of Knight E4 I fork
the knights
Bishop D5
and the two moves are this and this
at least as far as I remember
I played this a handful of times I can
determine play
Rook p8s I think Rook B8 was
anticipating I'd use the bishop D5
there's a funny idea to share a story of
your best have a chess win
um I can
but do I share it during this game
it might be slightly unrelated
okay I think G5 wins the piece
actually I've studied the same idea
where like white goes for this
abandoning the epon
and it can't be taken by either piece
because of tactics
yeah that could have played this earlier
[Music]
um
I could transpose
yeah my best ever win
um I mean I have a handful of like very
memorable wins
I mean for one
beating magnets Magnus Carlson the first
time I've ever played him
I played him unknowingly because he was
playing anonymously
and only after the game I found out
uh it was him on the account
I was streaming it this was back in I
think 20 early 2018
[Music]
and then later that year
the clip of my stream I posted to
YouTube a YouTube video uh reached the
front page of Reddit
for our slash videos
so that was pretty memorable
I want to take but it's not quite neat
my wife is a big fan of herbal teas what
are your very favorite herbal teas
especially the eclectic ones she'd love
to know
I almost misheard that I almost heard it
as a big fan of her baltis
I was wondering what balties are
but herbal teas yeah are um
are nice I mean there's a huge variety
I'm enjoying one um
it's called Egyptian licorice
it's a tea by Yogi
kind of naturally sweet
nice blend
another one is um another one by Yogi is
this
something called like soothing caramel
at that time
Tim Ferriss recommends it
and chamomile tea
I know people
say or pronounce chamomile differently
chamomile or chamomile
okay I'm dreaming of Anastasia's Meats
[Music]
um
but that involves this this with the
rook and then later meets
easier said than done
G6 is coming to
I could forth the Rooks
I just Fork the Rooks here
abandon the Knight
if rooked Yates I take the Rook
if that Rook dates I don't take the Rook
maybe 97
really trying hard for Anastasia's mates
for those that don't know
um hopefully I can make it happen
let's play this
getting closer
I mean I can just take the thing yeah
I'll just take the thing
okay
so Anastasia's mate is usually when you
sack on each seven and then deliver the
The Rook mates within Island E7
um
but what happened the game also kind of
worked out
okay
and so this person winning every game
poor connection
but not so poor result
14 minutes left
Magnus seemed really excited to get a
raid from you I saw that Tuesday nice of
you to help an up and coming streamer I
was so uh yeah it felt so good to help
uh up and coming streamers
Rose and rage hey yes
did that actually happen it did
everybody confirm I'm confirming
hi did I win the tournament or did I get
raided by Rosen
maybe both I'm a happy camper yay not a
not a manual right
thank you so much
I hope you had a good nice stream oh
that's so kind he's so awesome
that's what good streamers say no yeah
oh that's so nice
I feel so acknowledged right now
as my first time reading Magnus too
yeah at first I thought he like wouldn't
even acknowledge it
but then like people in chat were
telling him that I rated and then he he
was he said something like oh did Eric
really raid
it was like thanks for the raid hope you
had a nice dream it was like very
wholesome
and then right after like I sent the
raid I realized I should have just
stayed live to react to his reaction
but I ended the Stream So what I did was
I recorded my reaction I actually have
the recording of me reacting to him
and I might I might upload that as like
a YouTube video or short or something
I gotta move faster
I deserved hearty less than a minute
um the position's not too bad
a mishmash of pieces in the center
and knights and Bishops are
they they formed the cube very
rectangular
and then I play someone the other day it
was called killer rectangle
this looks like a killer rectangle
um
I gotta move a lot quicker
but I don't know what to do
play this
because Bishop B3 is coming
King should be here
okay B3 makes me happy
Bishop before
maybe Knight G8 just for safety
okay seven
yeah this and this
okay
my Bishop's just doing in White's crib
also what are my pieces doing
I don't like the way I'm playing this
but there's no time to have regrets
I mean I got some nice connect six King
pawns and Bishop
the queen wants to come in and join the
party
oh now it's White's Bishop in my crib
I think I just take that
try and win the pawn
oh triple Fork potential
use
oh okay connect five with the Pawns
how do I Harbor the hover needs a B7 I
got the move a lot quicker
happy
pushy pushy
that's what the pawns say
[__] [__]
don't my queen
[__] [__] oh no
if I took it would have been made ah
what a cool position though
oh I got a little bit to carry the way
there a little bit too long time to
oh what a crazy position
okay
um
yeah my chances are not so great but
I'll try
double dessert that's nice
okay
not sure if this is theory
looks very safe for for black though
hmm
I should have played um Bishop B6
a better Square
triple up the Rooks
okay threatening the smothered Fork
mates or smothered pork mates
it was almost a smothered something mate
um
light's not letting it happen though
I want to play this move
okay
triple battery
bring the Knight back
yeah we're just Trading
I'll trade some more I'll play Knight C5
winning this Pawn
hmm
I think Asics coming
there is maybe 95 there
thank you
[Music]
why is it so confusing
so many holidays
lights are so tricky
Mr free nights come back
happy holiday
oh it's a draw
oh wow I think that's a fair result
right
oh
that's a lot of hot in these
I'm not gonna win this tournament
but we're having fun that's what matters
oh what a game
playing Jay Hudson okay
the bird
is a word this is a bird defense
um
okay now it's some sort of Gambit
I'm kind of improvising here
but don't think this should be too bad
for me
I'd like to expand
Knight G3 what is happening
Queen G2
the hobbies are not going to last longer
for black
a knight is pretty much trapped
um
I mean I'm
let's just take
I'm keeping things simple
I'll lose a pawn wow
does not want to keep things simple
hey it's Rosie chess
saying something about being beautiful
thanks for returning
I appreciate your words
um I should have taken the Rook
although maybe I maybe it was fine not
to
The Rook is going to be kicked around
oh
okay it's still okay
I got my knight
um
okay so the king is well placed Rook is
well placed
foreign
s are well placed
okay time for one more game maybe
yeah it's not enough though
I would have needed five I would need to
be on a streak
let's play the um the Roy Lopez counter
Gambit
is Rosen More Beautiful on the
chessboard or off the chessboard
I mean that's that's coming from a
fallow Rosen right
also look at this beautiful opening crap
I learned this right before the
tournament
it's so beautiful King E2 A6
this is the one like I studied before
the tournament
the fitting ending I think I'd play this
now
I'll win back the piece
yeah it's not likely this game will
count for the tournament but maybe it
will
oh one more game
doll pairings are closed
I had my Hoops up I need one word to
have a chance
GG
that was fun I hope people enjoy that
had a couple losses man this one loss
was crazy
and then the first game
was also kind of crazy
congratulations
otic MJ
um if this does go on YouTube
let me know if you enjoyed the video let
me know if you want to see more thematic
opening tournaments
and if so let me know which openings you
want to see
and stay tuned for more content